2,5 millionen views auf klicks um ihr im monat wahnsinn aber dazu gleich mehr auch wenn die szene
Aus dem ersten star wars film schon 40 jahre alt ist vielleicht kennst wie der ein oder andere ein
aufgezeichneter hilferuf von prinzessin leia wird von r2d2 als
dreidimensionales video in den raum projiziert seitdem tüfteln forschungsteams weltweit daran genau das in der realität
wahr werden
Zu lassen und tatsächlich es gibt erste wirklich super spannende erfolge mal wieder ein vorschlag von whatsapp und dazu jetzt die
allerwichtigsten facts zum thema in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Zweieinhalb millionen views im monat was für ein wahnsinn damit hätte ich wirklich nicht gerechnet weil für den wissenschafts kanal ist das absolut rekordverdächtig
tausend dank also an alle die mich hier unterstützen ich bin wirklich super happy und besonders auf whatsapp
Da kommen ja echt total coole themenvorschläge rein einfach nur der hammer
Also allen hier einen riesigen dank dafür dass er hier so regelmäßig meine videos schaut kommentiert bleibt und weiter verbreitet
ja vielen vielen vielen vielen dank und deshalb
Habe ich zum schluss noch eine kleine überraschung für euch ihr könnt die realität verändern wie das geht und zwar hier
Im video das erkläre ich am ende es wird eben auswirkungen auf die videos hier auf dem kanal haben in jedem fall wird es
lustig ja die bislang entwickelten technologien waren nur halb gelungen entweder waren die 3d
Projektionen in der luft oder auf plasma einfarbig oder sie hatten eine minimale auflösung aber jetzt das ist wirklich der wahnsinn
Die jetzt entwickelte 3d projektion ist hochauflösend
Schwebt frei im raum und kann von allen seiten angeschaut werden dazu daniel smith von der
universität unter wir nennen es auch scherzhaft unser prinzessin leia projekt wir wollten die 3d displays aus der science fiction
wirklichkeit werden lassen
Wichtig hierbei es handelt sich nicht
Um ein gewöhnliches hologramm sondern um eine volumetrische projektion
im gegensatz zur hologramm haben solche volumetrischen projektionen
Tatsächlich drei dimensionen hier ist der blickwinkel nicht eingeschränkt es ist also tatsächlich
Möglich sich um das volumetrische display zu bewegen und es von allen seiten zu betrachten
anders bei einem programm das als zweidimensionale projektionen lediglich einen 3d effekt
erzeugt
winzige partikel durch leser manipuliert machen das möglich das ist ein wenig wie ein 3d drucker völlig wir drucken
Gewissermaßen ein frei im raum schweben das objekt mit diesen partikeln das sagt molly die
Partikel sind nur rund zehn mikrometer klein und bilden so die pixel ein
unsichtbarer laserstrahl bewegt sie und ordnet sie an sobald die anordnung passt werden die partikel mit roten blauen und
Grünem licht beleuchtet und zwar mit hilfe von rgb die so das sichtbare licht erzeugen auch ein dreidimensionales video kann
So projiziert werden da der leser die partikel bewegt bisher sind so schon
schmetterlinge leuchtenden ringe und eine version der berühmten szene aus star wars entstanden eine gestalt mit
bittend erhobenen armen leer hier statt als prinzessin aber
Im laborkittel und abgesehen von solchen spielereien können sich die produktion auch, hinsichtlich ihrer auflösung sehen lassen
1600 dots per inch das wurde so bislang noch nicht erreicht ein anderes wirklich nennenswerte das forschungsergebnis wurde vor etwa drei jahren
Vorgestellt ein forschungsteam aus japan hatte ein
holografische display entwickelt das 3d bilder in der luft schweben lässt das besondere hierbei diese bilder können gefahrlos
Angefasst werden diese entstehen auf eine andere art und weise als prinzessin leia
Im laborkittel und zwar mit hilfe eines lesers der lichtimpulse abgibt diese haben eine dauer. Im zweistelligen
femtosekunden bereich die lichtpulse
ironisieren moleküle
am fokuspunkt
zu einem plasma dadurch geben diese luftmoleküle energie ab in form von photonen also licht diese
lichtpunkte werden dann zu bildern kombiniert noch sind die bilder, recht klein sie haben ein volumen von etwa einem kubikzentimeter
Doch weil die pulse so kurz sind können sie problemlos
Angefasst werden das tolle das display reagiert sogar auf berührungen berührt man es mit dem finger
leuchtet das display heller zudem spürt man einen kleinen impuls auf dem finger da das plasma schockwellen
Produziert ja dennoch völlig ungefährlich für die haut so das forschungsteam, im gegensatz zur netzhaut
da ist ein schutz
Notwendig war na ja so und jetzt hatte ich ja etwas versprochen ich habe nämlich eine wette mit mir selbst wenn ich diese
unglaubliche zahl erreiche
Zweieinhalb millionen views im monat ist immer noch wirklich fahren sind dann. Habe ich mir die haare in einer verrückten farbe
Im moment bin ich single da gibt's keinen ärger und jetzt kommt es die ihr könnt die farbe bestimmen heute abend mache ich eine
abstimmung auf whatsapp welche farbe nicht nehmen sollen meldet euch also hierbei whatsapp under könnte dann mit bestimmt dann vater
zudem vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video vorab garantiert von mir ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von pixum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen und eben bei abstimmungen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter dafür auch. Draufklicken smarthome die zukunft des lebens ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleib dran